(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This may look
like just another car factory,
but it's actually a new microfactory,
manned by autonomous robot dogs
and robotic arms monitored by AI.
It's designed to change
the way cars are produced,
and it's been built in the
heart of one of the smallest
and most expensive countries
in the world, Singapore.
Typically, car manufacturers
don't build car factories
in dense urban cities like Singapore,
but here it's gonna be different
for most car factories.
Robots are going to do a
lot of the manufacturing
and it's gonna be a much
more flexible model.
- [Narrator] Microfactories
reinvent the way cars are made
by automating most of the process
and building them in a cell
rather than along a production line.
- This could be the
future in which we talk
in a couple of years from now.
- [Narrator] Microfactories
are one of the biggest changes
to car making in a generation
and if the concept is proven,
it could shape the future of the industry.
For over a hundred years,
cars have been built in large plants,
manned by hundreds of workers.
The trend has been towards
building bigger factories.
Tesla's Gigafactory facility
located near Austin, Texas,
covers more than 10 million square feet
of factory floor space,
and has the capacity
to build more than
250,000 vehicles a year.
By comparison, Hyundai's, new Microfactory
in Singapore stands just
over 935,000 square feet.
The car makers to the plant could produce
up to 30,000 cars a year.
Hyundai has pushed aside the
traditional assembly process
to allow for a much smaller footprint.
- Behind me, there are robots
that are putting together
the final finishing touches on a car.
Typically, in a more conventional
manufacturing process
that would actually
largely be done by humans,
it would be done in a long assembly line
which doesn't allow
for much customization.
(bright music)
- [Narrator] In
traditional auto factories,
vehicles travel along a linear path
and parts are installed
along an assembly line.
While the procedure is
increasingly automated,
the basic process hasn't
significantly changed.
- Here it's different.
It's a cell-based model, which means
that there are different
cells around the factory floor
where they're are focused
on different tasks,
and that actually allows
for a lot more automation.
- [Narrator] In each
cell, robots are tasked
with installing several components
of the car before it's
moved to the next zone.
Cells can be modified with
different instructions,
from installing parts in
an identical car design,
to assembling a different
vehicle altogether.
Hyundai says that more than 50%
of the manufacturing process
at its Singapore microfactory
is done by robots.
Automated ground vehicles move
the cars around the factory,
while four-legged robots
equipped with AI cameras monitor
and analyze the assembly.
Issues identified by the robot dogs
are then fixed by human workers.
- Even though we're a small factory,
we're producing cars
as a mass manufacturer.
So what allows us to do that is the usage
of flexible automation and a large portion
of systems intelligence behind
to orchestrate the manufacturing.
- [Narrator] Hyundai says,
because production is highly automated,
only about a hundred
workers would be needed
to produce the plant's capacity
of 30,000 cars per year.
That means a worker at the
microfactory could produce two
to three times the number of cars
compared to a person in
a traditional factory.
- For sure, we will still
need large scale factories.
We will still need to produce as many cars
as possible the most effective way
when it comes to overall mobility.
But we feel that the
answer is not only that,
and that in an urban environment,
having a smaller factory
that allows us to produce
as many different types
of mobility devices in
a cost-effective way
is absolutely critical.
- Hyundai's plant in Singapore
is the country's first auto
factory in over 40 years.
While microfactories could
allow wealthier countries
to rebuild manufacturing industries,
the move toward greater automation
will mean fewer manual jobs for workers.
- In a typical assembly
plant, you would think
for the assembly operation
of high single digit
to double digit percentage of automation
of automated tasks, we
are at around 50% already.
When it comes to logistics,
the provision at the right time
of the right part to the right cell
is again something where we've
automated over 60% already.
It's also in very low double
digit in other factories,
it's essentially manual.
- [Narrator] Microfactories
are largely untested ground
for the auto industry.
Arrival, an EV startup
producing vans has committed
to manufacturing their
vehicles out of microfactories.
However, the company has
only delivered a small number
of the vehicles that forecasted
out of its plant in the UK.
Arrival has struggled
to ramp up production
and a push back a plan second
microfactory in the US.
For now, Hyundai says it's
the only major car maker
to start building vehicles out of one.
- We have a thesis for
the future of mobility.
As we test the market, if we
realize that this is right,
you could see smart urban mobility hubs
in many different urban environments.
- [Narrator] While the
concept behind microfactories
remains unproven at a mass scale,
they provide a glimpse into
what car making could look like
as the industry heads towards a future
that is more automated.
(gentle music)